[Music]  you have very loyal fans to the point of  we actually that one fan had a tattoo if  you put on their body usually it's  something pretty simple this is the most  detailed depiction of you I think it's  fantastic that I would be scared if I  saw him in that weird which part of the  body is that by the way I don't know  yeah is that an inner thigh here's over  that's your that's you trying to figure  out where you are on the body what's  upstairs  what's downstairs why are my fingers  bleeding that's what I'd like to know it  must be the inner thigh yeah  your bad guy you're a bad bad guy  happens when that they start losing  their figure I'll look like Don Knotts  your your eyes in that it will be even  more lopsided  [Music]